[Música]
no
son responsables como autores de los
delitos contra los deberes de humanidad
cometido en contra de la población maya
[Música]
también quedó reflejado que sí que el
estado tiene una responsabilidad ante la
creación de las patrullas de autodefensa
civil ante la implementación de la
violencia sexual como una estrategia
durante el conflicto armado interno que
buscaba no sólo destruir el cuerpo de
las mujeres sino también destruir a
comunidades enteras
estoy contento porque ya nos hicieron
valor de nuestro testimonio lo que pide
yo ahorita ya no queremos que no vuelva
a repetir lo que pasamos nosotros ya no
queremos venganza porque aquí no estamos
para venganza
[Música]